[Música]
hace aproximadamente 70 años
se nos dice que entramos en la era de la
información y el conocimiento
eso es completamente falso
hace 3.3 millones de años por lo menos
entramos en la era de la información y
el conocimiento cuando las primeras
tribus en etiopía
descubren que al tallar una punta de
piedra y convertirlo en una lanza
pueden empezar a cazar animales que en
ese momento se pensaba imbatibles
y mejoraron la calidad de vida de las
tribus
quizás este pedazo de información
este de conocimiento
esta tecnología tan rudimentaria basada
en piedras
era el equivalente en ese momento al
internet de nuestros días
aseguraron con este conocimiento la
continuidad de la especie y la
continuidad de este conocimiento
a lo largo de los años se fueron
desarrollando nuevas ideas se fue
conociendo diferentes fuerzas de la
naturaleza y se empezaron a desarrollar
más y más conocimientos al punto en que
un jefe tribal por sí solo ya no podía
administrar tantos conocimientos
se generan de esta manera los
especialistas
con el paso de los años adelantado unos
cuantos millones de años
se crea la primera universidad del mundo
a la universidad de bolonia con la
finalidad de empezar a organizar la
información
establecer parámetros y estándares que
pudieran certificar que un alumno o un
aprendiz que había pasado por un curso
tenía los conocimientos suficientes para
desarrollar un oficio o una profesión de
manera satisfactoria
con el paso de los años
se empiezan a ver diferentes se empiezan
a desarrollar diferentes intercambios de
conocimiento y haber más ramas del
conocimiento y mayor estandarización
y eso nos trae al día de hoy
quiero partir de la premisa de qué
todo en el mundo todo lo que ocurre
es un proceso productivo
sea creativo o destructivo
bajo esa premisa hoy la educación es un
commodity
y lo voy a explicar sé que estoy una
universidad muy prestigiosa pero vamos a
explicarlo
en primer lugar el alumno o aprendiz que
recibe información a quien se le
traspasan conocimientos
se convierte en un insumo de un proceso
productivo el proceso productivo puede
ser 100% mental
100 manual o cualquier mezcla intermedia
pero al fin y al cabo un profesional o
un aprendiz que aprueba
satisfactoriamente un curso
es un insumo en segundo lugar este
insumo se transa en el mercado existen
mercados el mercado laboral si lo
quieren ver esa manera o las referencias
hay los headhunters e infinidad de
diferentes
mercados donde podemos buscar el insumo
que estamos buscando tiene un precio de
mercado
como un commodity co estos son los
salarios
en cuarto lugar son intercambiables no
lo tan personal yo nunca lo tomé de esa
manera pero si alguien sale de una
organización pues puede ser haber sido
ascendido o se va a otro lugar
la organización va a buscar a otra
persona
que tengan los mismos conocimientos
otra vez quizás de una carrera o quizás
de los conocimientos actuales de alguien
con una capacitación adicional
pero es intercambiable
y finalmente la calidad es casi
homogénea
estas variables son las que por consenso
definen un commodity ahora subrayo la
palabra casi
por qué
es ahí donde tenemos y encontramos la
esperanza
así es esa grieta que oxigena el mundo
casi es el insumo que no reacciona de la
manera esperada en el proceso productivo
el que interpreta el conocimiento de
otra manera le da un valor diferente o
lo usa de manera diferente
en ese sentido
el verdadero poder del conocimiento si
estamos de acuerdo que el conocimiento
es poder
está en el aprendizaje continuo y el
desaprendizaje continua
en parte el desaprendizaje me refiero
por ejemplo los prejuicios oa pedazos de
conocimiento que hoy ya no son válidos
y en este en esta búsqueda del
conocimiento de la verdad
es que se genera la paradoja de que
alguien que está aprendiendo algo y
quiere llegar a ser un experto o un
maestro
nunca verdaderamente va a dejar de serlo
y tiene que aferrarse a la idea
de que es algo que nunca va a alcanzar
pero que igual se puede invertir en el
camino
espero que hoy este planteamiento
matemático todos podríamos estar de
acuerdo si seguimos las reglas de la
aritmética uno más uno es dos estos
conocimientos
en este caso usted creen que el
conocimos este conocimiento es poder
qué poder nos da saber que uno más o
menos
a veces tienen que venir personas como
joaquín sabina
y decirnos que 2 no es igual a 11 y
convertir esto
en esto
eso es poder
interpretar bajo la licencia artística
bueno podemos dar la licencia que
queramos pero interpretar el
conocimiento de una manera única que
inspira al mundo eso es poder
el alumno sentido a esa ecuación
por la ecuación anterior por lo menos
ese valor agregado
es el verdadero poder del conocimiento
el doblarlo buscarle los errores
doblarlo de nuevo hasta encontrar un
punto que digamos
este es mi planteamiento único de lo que
es la verdad
la famosa frase la podemos cambiar por
esto
con gran conocimiento entonces tenemos
una gran responsabilidad si podemos
inspirar al mundo
con nuestra idea única
con nuestra interpretación particular
yendo más allá de lo que actualmente
donde actualmente estamos investigando
más
eso es poder
tenemos que entender que el conocimiento
para que sea poderoso tiene que ser
dinámico
y tiene que tener una interpretación que
nos sirva a todos
quiere hablar la responsabilidad que
está detrás del poder y esta es una
opinión obviamente pero creo que está
sustentado en dos sabias señoras
doña prudencia doña modestia
prudencia en el momento de recibir la
información
no digo que vamos a verificar
absolutamente todo lo que escuchemos
pero ser prudentes de quién
a quien escuchamos a quien no peleemos
ya quién no
y modeste al momento de compartir la
información que tenemos porque
inmediatamente después de decirle a esa
información puede ser inválida
tratamos de que el conocimiento es
dinámico
bajo esta
pequeña premisa
en la medida en la que tengamos
responsabilidad sobre el poder dejamos
abierta la puerta a todos los días ser
mejores
mejores personas mejores ciudadanos
mejores mejores esposos mejores amigos y
eso el mundo lo necesita
desesperadamente muchas gracias
[Aplausos]